this week we've got free the crackers
baby joyride and even flesh-eating STI
FBI I think yeah I think car but that's
2018 STD we can't say disease that makes
them feel bad about themselves I don't
have an infection I like your [ __ ]
gross [ __ ] [ __ ]
you should all be put into a pen in
Texas out of the middle of nowhere all
by your goddamn self don't come near me
don't look at me zombie perps age I
don't care what it is you're all in
there everybody gets a little SD cracker
time to time I feel like your normal
wavelength together you know we're
normally here but don't see STI what is
the STI what's the difference between
STI it says the sjw's runaround SAS
needy no I'm Felix I'm not disease or
disease I thought that election when
that was announced people who had the
super easily yeah I thought it was like
all better STD is incurable and sti's
are curable that's why they I could be
being a dick but I think it's literally
just because they're offended oh well
[ __ ] cares like after you just have a
discussion you go Oh spongebob me like
that use me Mesa will be rainbow it says
nobody cares oh yeah that was I just a
little bit uh it's they're still called
STDs STI is but the reason why now the
majority of people call it a CI is
because it's technically not because you
can do get it's an infection
oh that's why they prefer to call it as
tears we could still call it a CD anyway
alright I take back my rant all right
you guys can live with us
I'm sorry go just go curious so it was I
was I right in my assumption it's not it
yeah yeah it sounds like you're right
well who the [ __ ] cares well they're
saying that STI is an infection of C
these are transmitted disease
so like venereal diseases is would be
like as TVs in gerbils
I was right yeah anyway so the STDs need
to be pent up the FCI's can walk amongst
the noisy well yeah you can hang with us
[Music]
first stories here we're talking about
animals okay got leprosy [ __ ] that keep
going keep going
I got your back to Hamilton eyes alright
so for the first story we're talking
about animal crackers oh well frosted no
yogi anon frosted animal crackers you're
a psycho
they're just brown yeah and they come in
the little box like a circus trailer
which is I've never seen a real circus
trailer like the lion side to see if you
didn't pulled behind a bucket at the box
I never cared for the crackers yeah I
think it's not doing it it has this
weird aftertaste like it it doesn't it's
not a cookie but it's not a cracker
you don't like these no I scratch that I
don't like her either I like my old ones
yeah yeah they dip it in white chocolate
it um put sprinkles on yeah that's my
shoes are falling I have a very popular
unpopular opinion because I would rather
have these taste
what do you you're gonna hail that
cracker yeah the cracker has a weird
aftertaste like a stay or some [ __ ]
cracker a general or maybe it wasn't
when they were still no they don't
remember I was always so disappointed
because the packaging is so dope and as
a kid I always wanted it but then as
soon as I'd open it Ernie I'm like why
is this an animal crackers and not a
frosted animal cookies oh [ __ ] you're
right think so
cuz animal cookies come in a little
white bag yeah anima animal cracker
animal cookie michaels animal crackers
still that's what I thought but now in
my head I think the ones that we all
like cookies I don't care I cannot tell
what animal they are they're all just
blobs like they're animal cookie they're
[ __ ] good they're all elephants I
yeah right do you feel about these
cookies so thank you for bringing cuz
they're they're animal circus peanut
from the forties whether Dumbo's it with
the racist crows at will so I'm glad you
brought a peanut because you see this
has always been the bar no no morning
we're not animals crackers I never knew
about barn door over a century this has
been the packaging for these cookies but
back in 2016 Peter wrote a letter and
asked them to portray these animals not
in cages anymore but in their natural
habitat they changed packaging that's
pretty cool whatever dude the glass or
else suck you know we need I wish pure
[ __ ] wrote a letter from Peter Peter
Peter Griffin
like Peter I wish I wish Peter wrote a
letter and got angry at how bad that
[ __ ] the crackers did like Peter
should do that Peter from PETA oh my god
just writing it now
PETA a joke like that no PETA PETA she's
like what you have me she's like no no
peanut peanut no there was a segment of
that so people for Ethical Treatment of
Animals physically oh no Peter Peter
okay
isn't there bigger fish to fry you know
I've never been part of PETA or anything
already sure there's a whole tribe yeah
that's one thing yeah we're pretty sure
they're like sending multiple things a
little soldier ants but that's still it
like there isn't they're bigger fish to
fry though uh there is and they're
probably find those fishes as well
they're really fight they don't fried
fish because I'd be [ __ ] okay maybe
pitas like a gang yeah and like okay
where's the different tiers their
tariffs right no yeah becoming chronic
animal shelter here ripping out bars and
[ __ ] dude they kill a lot you're
borderline yeah I don't know if they're
officially on the list no I think
they're illegal because they've done
crimes before that are considered done
go to an animal shelter just it like
start ripping on doors and windows let's
also yeah I so this is this is my thing
their game okay so just like a gang yep
the interns have to do the patient okay
and then it's like to of yourself in the
PETA world and it's like then you get to
the top to your [ __ ] where your pants
are like chase the Wailers down and then
you hang out by their boats and [ __ ] so
they don't [ __ ] catch any whales I'll
and you just keep going
spray-paint the fur coats oh and then
that is the that's like purse snatching
yeah I know you got to get to that level
where you you put paint you peoples fur
coats you think it's an intern right in
Nabisco just for shits and giggles I'm
gonna take down the bisque oh now you
gotta do this [ __ ] and then they get
like some type of clout within the PETA
gang yeah like what I don't think they
talk and in an organized and say all
right [ __ ] Jimmy you write the letter
[ __ ] Peter yeah you you know you
[ __ ] do the animal yeah yeah
must be really shitty to be a guy named
Peter in Boston beat up alright for our
next story there's this crazy video
that's circulating circle Odin breaking
one of those this takes place in India
and you can see in the video you know
what I'll just let you see it thank you
they need to wipe that [ __ ] lens no
they flirting on purpose oh those
arranged for the bike is still rolling
gonna read it oh it's still wrong that's
what's crazy it's crazy as it just keeps
going it's really good advertisement for
a bike by the way it just keeps them was
that right is that on the front and the
kid just kept the bike going and them no
no I can just roll it myself
yeah we're gonna read it yeah no the boy
on another bike Oh to parents plan off
the bike a baby oh that's what that was
oh is the baby holding the ball - that
is the baby handled holding manic keeps
going until finally around the grassy
area the bike tumbles over the reason
why I know this is because that's how I
used to ride the scooters in Taiwan with
my grandpa so my grandpa rides in the
back and I'm standing in the front and
it's sometime so let me turn and
sometimes he'll let me like use
accelerator whatever something to say so
when someone fool off and I saw the
scooter keep going I'm gonna play on
over here oh I saw the clown I'm like oh
there must be a baby on there the baby
kept it balanced yeah you know what
happened the Indian spirits they said
baby not gonna die yet and then they
kept the motorcycle still but the adults
can go yeah but they didn't die right
there's just a trick because you can see
this bike for the longest time and then
nine
baby but I think the babies like it look
like I get to ride yeah it look like a
baby baby they don't they don't mention
the age thank god the baby didn't let go
the baby fell between minor bruises no
lobby
no helmets as I said I assume you know
that babies and toddlers are most more
likely to survive getting run over by a
truck than human yep there's no hundred
percent I wish I think which is that
their bones are still soft mhm
you're actually more fragile than
although you get I feel fragile yeah
yeah joints are bone you're [ __ ] my
emotions yeah I just get you're just
calcifying as a person then get out of
the old in just stuck can move yeah how
do I speak moist everything forties
don't you move my calls
that's how to move them hips Elsa don't
stop moving guys so I think you'll be
really good right yup yeah that wasn't
your flexibility yeah I mean anything's
good just move or some [ __ ] [ __ ] move
yeah we got to do it robos I'll not kill
myself no we're gonna do it together
sound like you're so old can you kill
yourself right Leonor will
okay sure thank you you can have my air
conditioning I like your shoes Irene
scream every club my god you would have
so much fun of the green screen the
dumbest should ever my clothes you know
my shoes my air conditioner your social
media accounts like a talk [ __ ] to
people and they think it's you yeah oh
my god yes okay you know that's two guys
this job when I die I need you guys to
go on my account and Kevon yeah I can't
do I don't care enough I gotta I'm gonna
I'm gonna expose most ya know the best
thing that Jim knows is she exposes the
dick pics and sends it to their family
that's so much effort though that's
awesome
you're in bed at 4:00 in the morning and
you can't sleep and you're watching
reruns of Bob's Burgers sometimes these
get [ __ ] done that's not a lot of effort
when someone sends you you click their
account and then you see who matches the
same last name and then you screenshot
and send them the picture or or or
usually they'll have you go under you
click their profile and then it says
sisters so whatever it's like one click
if they happen to be stupid enough to
leave it public
how much wouldn't that have been pretty
often really old because they're usually
like old creepy guys and old girls on
how to use Facebook yep
oh this is Facebook big pigs I know they
sent dick pictures they sound like some
crazy ass [ __ ] and it's like hey [ __ ]
you want a buck or whatever it is she
just screenshots it sends it to him
sends it to the family members it's
awesome I was like Danice doe I want to
be a coach just why censor it though
because I'm pretty sure they don't want
to see their uncle stick anyways oh
that's nice well it's speaking of dicks
with our last story here there's no
trouble yeah there's this flesh-eating
flex on your disc TV that's going around
irony but then other articles they put
eyes oh my god
anyway you what are you sleeping with
the kisser right
zombie [ __ ] dicks those things they
just evolve those diseases and bacteria
yes they evolve and so they're gonna eat
you they're saying that that this
particular disease or infection whatever
it's typically seen in India New Guinea
and parts of the Caribbean Central
Australia and southern Africa all the
dark dicks only Indian dicks it's a
queer dick later
yeah that's just equator dick so you
might be sick but this pale a snake is
staying around look cuz all those areas
is right by the equator yeah so good
this thing is called Donna
that's so weird
what's right on the quay turd how'd it
get to the Caribbean from where cribben
oh well that's words from but baby
[ __ ] out there what does that look
like I don't know I hear music in there
lay all the reggaeton had there its own
involvement globey clears it aligned
yeah not like some [ __ ] real there's
like a line and then your dick colors
like half darker to grow like a gradient
to it just goes right yeah like a
[ __ ] ice cream bar you know like that
rock went to white maybe put a tape in
finding it's just like a tan line a
lighter guy on top and just so dude
those are weird all dicks are weird I
think all of these look like
Frankenstein dicks cuz it's like your
skin is a different spin and then the
colour is different than the colour its
soul looks like a baby mole oh yeah the
one that doesn't see the sunlight yeah
the black ball yeah that's true or like
a hairless cat yep pull the wig stinks
the wigs oh yeah this is a weird so yeah
so this done what I know sis it has been
reported in an in a female patient who
isn't England UK oh it was between the
ages of 15 and 25 he's no Dark Ages
they can't so Google unnamed it's an
unnamed female patient like they're not
telling that she got this let's see what
you have any of your age range that's a
white chick that God was like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] in particular and his favorite one
[ __ ] I like God like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
in 40 hours give her a bad [ __ ]
disease maybe she went to the equator
got some equator yeah yeah
Moulton shows like party time Holly
they're back home started getting ulcers
lesion early so her vaginas getting
eaten yeah yeah it's like back to the
future when the family [ __ ] people
just start going to just become
invisible exactly that's why she never
hurt the birds like oh your vagina is
melting you don't think that's gonna
burn Alaska he's gonna feel great either
saying that antibiotic treatment may
stop the progression but the patients
are at risk of relapse for six to 18
months post treatment you know there's
[ __ ] like super gonorrhea and [ __ ] like
that right now
that's like resistant because a lot of
people get them and then it was it's
pretty common and then they take the
medicine but then they don't finish
taking the medicine and they keep
[ __ ] oh and it's so like there's like
antibiotic resistant similar Chloe food
yeah yeah yeah this was so crazy because
it's saying that if there's any delaying
treatment that this literally causes the
flesh around the genitals to rot oh boy
yeah I'm thinking I was thinking uh
what's that item Santa movie where he's
got the foot the black fellow yeah I'm
thinking yeah I'm thinking like coal
black
we're not punch it doesn't even hurt
because it's all none of the minute
asses to your regular skin it just stops
no you probably know like it's probably
spreading yeah I have integrity I don't
go past this girl lelu tubes and not in
the head that's what you meant like yeah
I thought it was like it only eats a
certain type of skin once it gets to
like your other skin a better date
that's again your dick head boy under
palms you Trinity cuz you're a different
type of skin yeah it was like off off
limits is different yeah I get one on
the arm but you're not gonna go in on
the palm here yeah I don't think it's
the same so I was like maybe it's like
that
yeah that's pretty crazy that's pretty
scary man that's why just jack off to
poor man don't try to have limited
amount of sex and they get treated in
yeah before and after every partner yeah
yeah cuz right here they're saying that
69% of ground it up or just come to you
and say 417 69% of the 1,000 British the
dalts that were pulled they said that
they had never been tested for me I've
never [ __ ] anyone in Britain maybe
they don't have maybe they don't have
Planned Parenthood like we do they don't
they have like universal baby yeah oh
yeah cuz okay so here's a big whistle if
you guys don't want to go to Planned
Parenthood which is free or with a
donation you if you're going to
university right now you can go to your
[ __ ] school nurse and say check my
[ __ ] dick that's international
didn't you can do that no universe like
you an emeritus America Oh like you
could just go to the student what do you
call it the health center and then don't
take your piss test I'll do all that
[ __ ]
mature and you'll give it back brown bag
of condoms some of them are flavored
some of us whatever my mini ten what
Planned Parenthood and you see me
sitting there Jenna refill my
birth-control can you not ask me for a
photo please
oh [ __ ] like that's the worst through
those the [ __ ] worse they come on
let's do it over here by the sign like
they walked in it and they're like hey
aren't you Gina and like this back when
I was younger and I was broke and then I
was like yeah and they're like cool so
what are you doing here like I'm like
abortion right try not to get pregnant
man I'm talking about [ __ ] birth
control okay I was like y'all girls get
your burger joy your toe like try to
take a photo with the you hold your
pills and [ __ ] damn time and place man
time in play did you see they took one
of you and spawn you naked yeah I was
changing house but [ __ ] I just finished
bed from the Korean spa and then this
guy I'm like by Megan comes up and he
goes oh can I get a picture I'm like put
my clothes on clothes on my clothes on
and we'll go outside that's why the
words I'm like it was like there's
literally sign that say you can take a
picture and all you see is he naked
dudes behind you you think he's so
didn't put his clothes on in the mirrors
behind them you can see birthday
[Music]